Speaker 1: Well, we are going to have a very
interesting Senate race for the Democratic
primary in California in 2024. Last week, we
talked on the bonus show about Congresswoman
Katie Porter announcing that she's running for
Dianne Feinstein's Senate seat. Dianne Feinstein
has been in the Senate about 30 years. She has
not yet actually said she is not running in 2024,
but Katie Porter has decided she is going to
run. The latest news is that Adam Schiff is
joining that very same race. NBC News reporting.
Adam Schiff running for Senate in California,
joining a crowded 2024 primary. So two
members of Congress now at minimum are
going to be fighting against each other.
Actually, three because of Barbara Lee.
Adam Schiff announced Thursday he's running
for Senate, joining what is expected to be a
crowded race. Feinstein has not announced her
plans, but already three prominent California
Democrats have set their sights on replacing her.
Schiff and Congress representatives Katie Porter
and Barbara Lee. Schiff says Democrats need
a fighter in the Senate who has been at the
center of the struggle for our democracy and our
economy. He looks forward to campaigning hard,
meeting Californians where they are and listening
to what they want from their next senator. You
know, I got a few emails from many of you
fine folks saying, David, isn't this isn't
this dangerous? Isn't this potentially going to
lose a Senate seat for Democrats in California?
I don't think that there's any risk of that.
I really don't. I think a hard fought primary
is fine and should be welcomed in most cases.
And California is very blue and in almost.
For sure terms. We can say that the winner of that
Democratic primary will be the next senator from
California. For me, the more interesting question
is, are these folks who are going to be running
against Dianne Feinstein? And I think there's two
dynamics at play that are going on now. Many this
is not the type of thing we make fun of. There
is a reality that there have been real concerns
cognitively about Dianne Feinstein for a couple of
years, reports that she will meet people regularly
in her course of being a senator and not remember
that she's met them before or multiple times.
We've even seen very kind of tough to watch
public situations where Feinstein will read a
question to a witness during testimony, during
a hearing, and then immediately read the exact
same question a second time with no recognition
that she's already asked that question. There
are real questions she's getting to to you know,
she's getting up there in age and we want to be
sensitive to all these things. Part of this
may be an effort to push her out by saying,
look, there's so many people running. There's
not even really a guarantee you would win. This
is a good time to maybe maybe move on. The other
speculation about why we are seeing so much early
announcement for this seat is that some of these
folks, Katie Porter, Barbara Lee, Adam Schiff,
they may hope that by announcing early they will
keep others from entering the race, by showing,
look, I'm a strong candidate, I'm well known, I
have a good shot at this thing. Don't even bother
getting involved. And I don't know whether anyone
has been dissuaded so far from entering that race
because of the early announcements. But it is
going to be a very interesting race. It's not
going to be a race that will be material in terms
of the balance. If Dianne Feinstein doesn't run,
she's going to be replaced by by one of
these Democrats because of California's
voting demographics. And so in that sense,
it won't be interesting to the balance,
but it will be an interesting race to see the
direction that Californians are are leaning.
I don't have a strong opinion about these three
right now, nor do I vote in California. So I am
not inclined to come out right now and say,
here is the one of these three that should
definitely be supported. I'm actually interested
interested in seeing how the campaign rolls on